The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TADGE DRYJA: Today we're going
to talk about synchronization--
how all these different
nodes on the network
come to consensus,
how they link up.
So it's sort of bringing
it all together.
So so far in these
lectures we've
talked about signatures,
mining and blocks, transactions
and scripts.
And now we're going to
put it all together.
How does this all actually work?
What do all these components
come together to do?
And how does this
make this cool money?
Quick recap on
signatures that I think
you got the idea
from the homeworks,
from the lectures-- you have
these public and private keys.
This key pair where you
generate the private key,
you distribute the public key.
The private key
can sign a message.
And anyone can verify, given
the triple public key, message,
signature group.
This is useful for
lots of things--
providing identity, ownership,
all sorts of things.
And it's better than
paper signatures.
Paper signatures don't
really sign the message.
They just sort of
sign the paper.
So if you change some
part of a document,
the signature still
sort of looks OK.
Maybe you can see--
you want the paper
to not be tampered.
But you can sign a
blank piece of paper
and then add all this
text on afterwards.
You can't do that
with these systems.
So signatures are really cool.
And they are sort of a necessary
thing for this network to work.
So mining and blocks--
I think you sort of got the idea
with the Lamport signatures.
If you've looked at the
current problem set,
it makes a lot of sense.
You change it nonce, hash a
bunch of times while you change
a nonce a bunch of times.
Try to get a low output.
So you get the idea of mining.
You're proving work
by repeatedly going
through different nonces, trying
to find a certain hash output
that there's no shortcut to.
You just have the
guess and check.
And now if you include
the previous data
as part of your input
to that hash function,
you can make a chain of work.
And that's what we call
a blockchain I guess.
Any questions on this so far?
It's the basic idea
from two lectures ago.
Cool.
And a recap of what
Neha said yesterday--
there's transactions
and scripts.
I'm not going to go
into scripts too much
yet, because in practice,
99% of the scripts
are just checking a
public key signature.
You can do all sorts of other
crazy things with the scripts.
But almost nobody does yet.
Basically they say, OK, I'm
sending to a public key hash.
When I spend from it, I
reveal the public key,
check that the hash
matches, check a signature.
And transactions have
inputs and outputs.
We went over this yesterday.
Just a sort of
real-world numbers,
this is how big
things are, "ish,"
so a transaction ID
and index to point
to a previous transaction.
The transaction ID is 32 bytes.
The index is encoded as a
four byte, so 32-bit integer,
which is kind of overkill,
because I think the most that
there's ever--
the most outputs
there's ever been
is like 1,000 or something.
So you really don't need it to
be able to go up to 4 billion.
But that's how it is.
The signature ends up
being about 100 bytes
because you have to provide
the public key, which is either
33 or 65.
And then the signature itself
is encoded to something
like 70 bytes.
Both of those things could
be much more efficient.
But they're not yet.
And the output is
actually a lot smaller.
An output, the script--
the main thing is
your public key hash,
which in Bitcoin is 20 bytes.
And then you have those
other little opcodes,
which it adds a
few bytes, and then
your amount, which is--
so all amounts in Bitcoin
are encoded as 8-byte,
signed 64-bit integers.
So you can have
pretty high precision.
And that's also overkill, since
all the bitcoins ever mined,
put together--
if you added them all up, it's
nowhere near 64 bits to the 64.
It's like 2 to the 40 something.
So it's also kind of
overkill but yeah, whatever.
So this ends up being for a one
input, one output transaction,
less than 200 bytes.
So that's a message,
pretty small.
You can broadcast it
around the network.
Inputs point to old
outputs, have signatures.
Outputs have scripts
and coin amounts.
So what do we do with
all these things?
What is the mining process?
So in the homework,
you're mining your name.
You connect to the
server, figure out
with the last block was, put
your name on, put a nonce,
and continue to mine.
That's not super useful,
unless you want to prove that
you're-- hey, this is me.
In Bitcoin, the
basic idea is users
are making these transactions.
Transactions are moving coins
from one place to another,
from one key to another.
They make the transactions, they
sign them, and they broadcast.
I'll get in to what
"broadcast" means.
So in the current
problem set, there's
one server, which is not really
a robust distributed system,
as people may have
seen yesterday
from about 1:30 to 3:00 PM,
when the whole thing went down.
In Bitcoin, it's
completely peer-to-peer.
Every node is the same.
They're all listening
for people connecting in.
They're all connecting
out to other nodes.
And they broadcast.
So if someone sends
you a message,
you'll pass it on to
all the other people.
So it's called a gossip network.
In practice, it works OK.
It's fairly heavy load
on some network traffic,
but you can make transactions,
sign them, broadcast them.
And then someone,
the miner, takes
all these recent
transactions that they've
seen, and puts them into a
block, and then does some work.
So those transactions
are now confirmed,
and people can build
the next block.
So the only difference from
the current problem set
is instead of putting
your name in, you put--
you can put your name-- but
you also put all these messages
that you've seen recently.
And so you commit
to them that way.
You could do it by just
sticking them all in,
but instead, there's a bit
more advanced way to do it.
You use what's called
a block header.
So yeah, the block header
itself is the message.
So similar to the problem
set, it's the block header
that you need to hash to get a
low output value, not the block
itself, which is
kind of interesting.
And the headers have a hash
of all the transactions
in the blocks.
So you don't just put
all the transactions
into one big megabyte
data structure,
hash the whole thing, and
then try to get a low output.
You actually do some
intermediate steps first.
And what's interesting
is it's actually
just the headers that
make a chain, not
the blocks themselves.
So instead of blockchain, you
could call it a headerchain.
So I'll talk about headers.
The headers are 80 bytes.
And they're actually quite
similar to the blocks
in problem set 2.
So the main three
components are you've
got the previous hash, the
Merkle root, and the nonce.
And so this is like
in the problem set.
You start with
the previous hash.
Then you have data that
you're actually committing to.
And then you have
some data that doesn't
have any actual meaning,
just to get the work done.
So I can-- to reference, if
you look through the work
people are doing right
now, this is all public,
the current problem set.
There's a previous
hash, which is basically
the hash of the line above it.
And then there's some data
you're committing to, in this
case people's user names, and
then some non-meaningful data
here with just random numbers
and stuff it looks like--
so very similar.
Any questions about this idea?
Cool.
So we use a Merkle root, which
I think I talked about last week
Monday, instead of
just concatenating
all the transactions and
hashing them in together.
You could do that.
That actually would work.
It wouldn't make
a huge difference.
But this is a
little nicer if you
want to prove that a
transaction was in this block,
without giving the whole block.
So the idea is I
have these TXIDs.
And a TXID, transaction ID, is
just a hash of the transaction.
Stick all the components of
the transaction into bytes,
hash that, and you've
got what's called a TXID.
And that's how you
refer to transactions.
You hash these two together to
get this intermediate point.
Do the same thing
up to the root.
And so you can't change any of
these little transaction IDs
without changing
the Merkle root.
So it commits to
all the transactions
just the same way it would
if you just concatenated them
all together and hashed that.
So it really-- we'll go in
to, later, why this is useful.
But in many cases, it really
doesn't help too much.
Any getting questions
about Merkle, Merkle tree?
Good.
So the actual Bitcoin headers,
which many things use,
has a couple of fields.
Some of them are
actually not very useful.
But the main two are previous
hash, Merkle root, nonce.
And then there's-- I'll
talk about the other things.
So there's also a version
field right at the beginning.
It's 4 bytes.
It indicates block version.
It's not clear what that's going
to be used for in the future.
It used to be used for sort
of signaling protocol changes.
I'm not sure that's going to
be the case going forward,
because it didn't really
work very well for that.
So right now I think they all
start like 02 and then a bunch
of zeros.
And that's the current
version, whatever that means.
And if you mine something
with a different version,
everyone will accept it.
But there'll be like these
warnings that show up
in your Bitcoin log files that
say, warning, unknown version
detected.
The idea is maybe, well, if the
inversion increases or changes,
maybe there's some new rules
in this system, or new opcodes,
or new something going on.
And you're not aware
of it, so you might
need to upgrade your software.
That was the idea anyway.
In practice, what happens is--
you'll see in your
logs all the time,
that like, unknown
version detected.
And it's just someone
just set random numbers
in the version field.
And it doesn't seem to mean
anything, so not super useful.
Previous hash, just
like in the problem set,
it's the hash of the
previous block, 32 bytes.
Merkle root, as described
a few slides before--
hash of all the
transactions in the block.
Time, actually kind of complex--
I'm not going to go into
the whole thing right here.
So far we haven't really
talked about time.
Does anyone know why we'd
want time in these headers?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You had
mentioned earlier
that you don't accept blocks
between a certain interval
if they were too late.
TADGE DRYJA: Right.
So it makes sense intuitively
that like if someone says, hey,
I mined this in 1987.
It's like well,
that seems crazy.
Or if someone says,
here's a block.
It came out in 2046.
Like, this doesn't
make any sense.
So intuitively,
yeah, you shouldn't
accept things that have
some crazy date that's
clearly wrong.
But why?
Why do we need time at all?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you want
to lock the transaction
until a certain time.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, you could
say, here's a transaction,
and I don't want it to
be valid before August 1.
And so then, you could say,
if it goes into a block,
and that block has a
timestamp before August 1,
consider the block invalid.
You could.
You can also do timestamping
based just on block height.
But what's the main-- does
anyone know the main reason
to have height here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is it
because if they're
a competing transaction?
And then you would
pick one or the other.
TADGE DRYJA: So the competing
transactions, when they get in,
they sort of get into a block.
And that sort of solves
that competition.
So you have two
transactions that
both are mutually exclusive.
Well, if they're both in the
same Merkle root and both
in the same block,
then that block
is considered invalid,
because it's like,
hey, you've given me a block.
It's got two things that
can't both exist here.
So throw the block away.
If you find two blocks
that both seem to have--
that sort of collide.
They're both pointing to the--
they've both got the
same previous hash.
So they're both in the same
height, we call, of the chain.
You could say, oh, well,
whichever one came out first.
I'll look at the
timestamp and say, OK,
the block that came out
first will be the valid one.
But the problem is this
is claimed block creation.
You can put whatever 4
bytes you want in there.
And so you can always
say, oh, I just
wanted it exactly 1 second
after the previous block.
It just took me a
while to broadcast it.
So you can't really
trust the timestamp
to see which came first.
If you could, you wouldn't need
all this crazy mining stuff.
And transactions themselves
could just have a timestamp.
And you wouldn't need
this whole structure.
So the fundamental
reason you're mining
is we can't trust people to
say when they did something.
You can always say, no,
this transaction came first.
No, this came first.
So the real reason
for this blockchain
is, OK, we know which
came before what.
AUDIENCE: In practice,
which one happens?
Do people just lie and say
it happened a second later?
Or is it [INAUDIBLE]?
TADGE DRYJA: Oh, in
practice the timestamps
are pretty unreliable.
They can be off by minutes.
It can be before the
previous block's time.
And that's OK.
It seems intuitively like, well,
that should just be a rule.
And it probably-- it would have
been cool if it was a rule and
made things simpler
from the beginning.
But if you're pointing
to a previous block,
I'm building on top of it.
And the previous block
came out at 10:15.
And I set my timestamp
to 10:12, 3 minutes prior
to the previous block.
Logically, that's impossible.
I'm referencing
something, and I'm
saying I'm coming before it.
But the software says that's OK.
AUDIENCE: So if we're
creating a version,
would it be useful to just
get rid of version and time,
like if we're creating
a new blockchain?
TADGE DRYJA: So version,
maybe you could get rid of,
or you could put it somewhere
in the Merkle root or something.
Time actually does have
a really useful purpose.
Does anyone, maybe if you know?
AUDIENCE: I don't
know, but does it
play into the
difficulty of the mine?
Does it?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, so
the main reason for time
here is to adjust
the difficulty.
And that happens
every 2,016 blocks.
You just look at, OK, how long
did this 2,016-block period
take according to
these timestamps?
And if it took two
weeks, OK, we're good.
The difficulty doesn't
have to change.
If it took three weeks,
that means the blocks
were coming out very slowly.
And we need to reduce
the difficulty.
If the 2,016 blocks came
out in one week, that means,
wow, people were
mining really fast.
And so we need to
increase the difficulty.
So there's this negative
feedback mechanism
based on this time.
And it can be tweaked.
It's not accurate.
You can have things
coming in the wrong order.
The general rule of thumb--
the rule in the software
is about two hours.
If you see something
that's two hours off
from what your internal clock
says, you will reject it.
But that's a huge gap.
Most network systems,
everyone's got their clocks
to the same second at
least, or millisecond.
Two hours is like
kind of enormous gaps.
But the system works
OK, because you've
got these really long-term
difficulty adjustments that
only happen every 2,016 blocks,
which in practice is something
like two weeks.
So if someone gets
something a few minutes off,
it doesn't really
affect things too much.
And it's really only used for,
OK, look at the last 2,016
blocks, two weeks-ish of
work, of all these blocks,
and see how fast we
need to make things.
So that ties into the next
field, which is difficulty.
It's in a sort of weird
floating pointlike
format with a mantissa
and exponent, which
is totally custom.
And you kind of have to write
your own code to deal with it.
But it basically
says, OK, what does
the number have to-- what does
the hash have to be below?
It's not just number of bits.
So in the problem set,
I said 33 bits of work.
So that's fairly easy to
detect, because you just look
for 33 0-bits in the front.
In Bitcoin, it's not
just number of bits.
It's actually a number
that it must be below.
If it were just number
of bits, the problem
then is your adjustments are
fairly coarse, because you can
only adjust by a factor of 2.
You can double your
difficulty or half it.
But with this, you can have much
smaller difficulty adjustments
of like a fraction of a percent.
Yeah, this field is
pretty much useless
since you can calculate
it from the time
fields of the previous blocks.
So you could just
have it be implied.
But it's in there.
And you can just whatever.
It's an extra 4 bytes.
I don't think you
actually-- like, you
don't have to store it
on a disk if you want,
because you can just figure
it out from the other things.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't you
need it for [INAUDIBLE]??
TADGE DRYJA: No, because you
can figure out what difficulty
is just from the headers.
I mean, it's in there.
I guess it's nice
if you just want
to validate whether a single
header has enough work.
But it's like, how much
work does it claim it needs?
And then you can validate it.
But I don't know.
It's in there.
It doesn't-- you could take
it out and reorganize the code
a little if you
wanted to optimize it.
But that would change so
much that no one bothers.
AUDIENCE: So when we talk about
the adjusting difficulties
and even just showing the
problem or proof of work, who
[INAUDIBLE] for
the problems that
will go to the central server?
TADGE DRYJA: So in
this, it's just everyone
broadcasts their blocks.
So if you've received a block or
if you found a block yourself,
you just send it to all your
peers that you're connected to.
And so there's no like, oh,
this is the canonical block.
There can be competing
blocks where you have two
at the same time and just
stochastically, one of them
will pull ahead,
because, well, randomly.
So you can have
conflicting things.
Yeah, and then the
adjustments-- also,
everyone computes
the adjustments.
And this is an actually
very quick computation,
because you're just looking at--
you're not even looking
at 2,016 timestamps.
You're basically just
saying, OK, if height--
so height is just what
block number it is.
So if you're-- right now,
it's about 500 million.
No, sorry, 500,000.
So you basically
in the code just
say, well, if
height modulo 2,016
is equal to 0, check
height minus 2,016's block.
Compare the two timestamps.
Subtract them.
Get a duration.
And then compare that
duration to two weeks.
And then change the
difficulty proportionally.
So it's actually, like,
super quick for everyone
to compute the new difficulty.
And they only do it
once every two weeks.
And it, yeah, it's
pretty straightforward.
There are weird
attacks and stuff.
And it's kind of some weird
off by 1 errors, where you're--
I don't remember.
Like, it's kind of confusing.
It's also confusing because
the test network, which
I haven't gone into but will
use probably in two weeks.
There's a Bitcoin test network,
which operates pretty much
exactly the same as
Bitcoin, except everyone
agrees that the coins
are not worth any money.
What's interesting is it's
actually called testnet3.
The first two test networks
have the same setup.
However, the agreement that
they were not worth any money
broke down.
So at testnet1,
someone said, hey,
I'll pay you a bitcoin for
a million testnet coins.
And once people
saw this happening,
they said, oh, well,
you just ruined testnet.
Now they're worth money.
So we'll go to testnet2.
It happened again.
Testnet3 has had
some staying power.
I think people realized that if
they try to buy testnet3 coins,
everyone's going to
leave and go to testnet4.
So it's kind of fun.
I'd actually be OK with testnet3
coins being worth money,
because I have many,
many thousands of them.
But yeah, so one
difference, though,
between the test networks
and the real network
is the difficulty adjustments.
So I think in the
first test network,
it just worked
exactly like Bitcoin.
But one of the problems
was people would mine,
and the difficulty
would increase.
And then people would
stop mining, say, oh, I'm
going to test out
my mining software.
I'll mine a couple
thousand blocks.
Maybe it only takes me
a day or two to do so,
because I have a very
fast computer compared
to the rest of the network.
And then I say, OK,
well, it works, cool.
I'm going to go to
the real network now.
And I leave the test network.
And now the
difficulty increased,
because let's say 2,000
or 4,000 blocks came out.
And they came out very quickly,
so the difficulty went up.
And then all the
mining power left.
And so now blocks
aren't coming out.
And since the adjustment
can be up or down
but happens based on number
of blocks, not based on time,
if you have a very high
difficulty and the very low
hash rate relative
to that difficulty,
it can take weeks
or months or years
for the difficulty to reduce.
So testnet3 put in this
sort of difficulty nerfing
code, which is probably wrong
and not what they intended.
And it has this thing where
like if 20 minutes have gone by,
the difficulty lowers.
And it's kind of ugly.
So that's the main place
I've dealt with this field.
One other rule with the
restriction-- the difficulty
can go up by at
most a factor of 4
and drop by at
most a factor of 4.
So if you mine 2,016
blocks in one day,
the difficulty goes
up 4x but does not
go up 14x or whatever
the implied would.
Any-- go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So the
difficulty is definitely
constant for two weeks then?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
Well, sorry, not two weeks--
2,016 blocks, which is generally
around two weeks, but yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it
unblocks and blocks,
within literally an
almost two-week period,
that difficulty
would be the same.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, so if you
actually look at the headers,
this is just the constant.
It just is always the same.
So it's kind of a silly
field to be in there.
You never need it, and
it's always the same.
Any other questions
about-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: How many transactions
are usually [INAUDIBLE]??
TADGE DRYJA: Oh,
I'll get to that--
right now, a couple
thousand, 4,000-ish.
We'll get to that I think.
But yeah, in the Merkle root--
so the height of the
Merkle root's like 12-ish.
And it goes out to maybe
4,000 transactions,
sometimes more,
sometimes very few.
You'll find empty
blocks that just
have one transaction in them.
And that transaction ID just
becomes the Merkle root,
because a height--
it's like a height-zero
Merkle tree,
but yeah, something like that.
And then last-- pretty easy--
there's a nonce, 4 byte.
Anything you want goes in there.
You can think of it
as a you went 32,
there's no meaning to it.
So does anyone see a problem
with this nonce field?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's too small.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah,
it's too small.
4 bytes-- even in
the homework, people
are using 12 something
bytes for a nonce.
With only 4 bytes of
nonce, you can go through 2
to the 32 possibilities,
which is not
enough to mine in
almost all cases,
because you're going to need
to go through 2 to the 70
possibilities to find a block.
So what are some ideas for how
do you deal with this problem?
Like, it would be nice
if it was just 8 bytes.
That'd make things simpler.
But the system is what it is.
It's very hard to change.
How, as a miner, would you
work around this issue?
AUDIENCE: Adjust the
version and time.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, so
you can adjust version.
So that may be why sometimes
weird version numbers come up.
Time is a good one
too, since time--
so yeah, adjust time
and also Merkle root.
So time, if you're off by a
few seconds, nobody cares.
So use the low bits of this time
field as part of your nonce.
It's kind of in the wrong
place, but you can make chips
to sort of fiddle--
twiddle these bits as well.
What's also nice is that
every second you can sort of--
you can do it the wrong way.
And you can say,
oh, I'm just going
to take the least significant
4 bits of my time field
and just use them as
nonce space randomly.
What's nice is that the
actual time progresses by one
bit every second.
So as long as your
chip has enough space--
so you're like, OK,
I've got 2 bit to 32
here, another 4 bits here,
so I'm at 2 to the 36.
If you're chip only goes
through 2 to the 36 hashes
every second, you're good
because the actual time
progresses.
The other way you can do it
is modify the Merkle root.
And you can do that-- so can
you think of ways to modify that
without breaking things?
AUDIENCE: Add or
drop the transaction.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah,
you could add or you
could drop a transaction.
So you say, OK, I have
all these transactions.
I'm going to drop one.
That's got some
disadvantages, because it
may pay fees to the miner.
AUDIENCE: Changing the order?
TADGE DRYJA: Yep,
you can swap them.
You can just say, OK, well,
these two are independent.
I'm going to swap them.
This will change,
which will change that.
So you can swap
transactions around.
You can also edit what's called
the Coinbase, which I think
is in like one more slide.
So yeah, so there's
a bunch of ways
that you can change things.
And so this is really
where you're going
to have all the variation.
You have 32-bit bytes here.
And just even if it
was just swapping,
and if you have 1,000
transactions, swap
in whatever order you want--
there's enough sort
of entropy there
that you'll be able to find it.
So what's interesting is
that the nonce is there.
And it's important,
because that's
where sort of the
high-speed mining occurs.
But most mining chips will also
have circuitry to modify this,
because they're operating
so quickly that they
will exhaust the
4-byte nonce space
in a fraction of a second.
And so they'll have to
swap two transactions,
recalculate a Merkle root, which
involves a few dozen hashes,
and then go back here.
So it actually doesn't hurt
their efficiency too much,
because, OK, I just did 4
billion hash operations.
And then I need to
do a few dozen more
to get to the next 4 billion.
So it doesn't hurt
things too much.
Also, in Bitcoin-- a
sort of weird quirk--
it's called SHA-256d.
They do SHA-256.
And then from the output,
they do a SHA-256 again,
not sure why.
I think in one person's
first problem set,
they inadvertently were
doing the same thing
and was like, yeah, that works.
Satoshi, whoever he
or she was, or they,
just put that in there.
Any questions about this header
in this format and anything
about it?
It's pretty compact.
It's 80 bytes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
including the Merkle root.
So if you end up
mining something,
you don't have to
put anything there.
So the only incentive
is the transaction fees?
TADGE DRYJA: In the
block reward, which I'll
get to in a second, but yeah.
That's a good question.
Can you put nothing
in as a Merkle?
I don't think so.
I'm pretty sure you
need one transaction.
AUDIENCE: Oh, that's right.
I mean, you need
the base for the--
because even if just did it, you
need a [INAUDIBLE] transaction.
TADGE DRYJA: You can do that.
And there's many blocks.
So in the first
year or so in 2009,
almost all the blocks are empty
and only have one transaction,
because no one was using it.
But people were mining.
So it was very similar
to the problem set, where
everyone's just mining,
and they're not actually
using the system.
AUDIENCE: Bu then right now--
TADGE DRYJA: Right
now there's tons.
AUDIENCE: People aren't doing
that just because there's
transaction fees.
TADGE DRYJA: Right now--
AUDIENCE: It's their
only incentive?
People just decided--
TADGE DRYJA: No, you
still get more bitcoins.
So you still get a reward.
The reason you'll see empty
blocks now is a little tricky.
We're not sure,
because who knows?
But it's probably because of
blind mining, where you receive
a block, and you
haven't actually
looked through the
contents of the block yet.
But you want to
mine the next block.
But you're not sure what
transactions to put in.
You see this 80-byte
header, and you're like, oh,
someone find a block.
But you only have
the header, and you
want to build on top of it.
You have a bunch of transactions
you'd like to put in,
but they may have already been
put into the previous one.
And so you're like,
well, I have no idea
what's in the previous one.
I'm just going to mine a
block with nothing in it,
that way I'm sure that
I'm not going to conflict
with my previous one.
You'll often see a block with
only one transaction very soon
after its predecessor block.
AUDIENCE: So like every once
in a while, it would check.
So you're saying if it happened
and went to a block really
quickly, there's just more
likely to be more transactions.
TADGE DRYJA: Right, right,
because a miner might--
it's actually an optimal
strategy for a miner
to say, look, first thing
I'm going do, download
the 80-byte header.
Figure out if it's got
a valid proof of work.
If it does, I'm
going to just assume
it's valid for the
next few seconds,
because it probably is.
And then I'm going to try to
mine a block on top of that.
Reference this previous block.
Mine a block on top.
The thing is, I have no idea
what's actually in the block.
I have no idea what contributes
to this Merkle root,
because I haven't even
downloaded that data yet.
But I can build on top of
it, just from the header.
But I can't include
transactions,
because I have no idea what
transactions are in here,
so they might conflict.
So I'll just mine sort of
blind for a second or two.
And then download all the
transactions, validate it.
And now I can include
my transactions
that haven't been included.
And so that happens.
It can be an OK strategy.
Sometimes it can lead to
you mining an invalid block.
If someone produces an invalid
block, and you just see, oh,
well, it's got proof of work,
you grab that header, start
mining on top of it.
No matter what you
mine, it's going
to be invalid, because it's
pointing to an invalid block.
That happened 2015 or 2016.
The summer of 2015 it happened.
And it was like quite extensive.
It was like seven
or eight blocks
in a row that were all invalid,
because none of the miners
were actually
verifying anything.
They were just downloading
the headers from each other
and being like, yeah, I
mean, you did the work.
So they were just
assuming everyone else
was verifying the Merkle roots.
And yeah, so then it ended--
so they lost 25 times 8,
however many bitcoins.
They lost hundreds of bitcoins,
which at the time was still
worth quite a bit-- and now
it's worth millions of dollars--
just because they weren't
actually checking things.
AUDIENCE: If I mine a
block and it's empty,
do I decrease my chances
of being mined afterwards?
TADGE DRYJA: No, actually,
I would say you'd, sort
of game theoretically, you would
increase it, because you're not
depleting the mempool.
I need to talk about
the actual mining
coinbase and mempool and stuff.
But yeah, it's a
tricky question.
And I'll try to get back to it.
If I don't, bug me again.
TX-- so in this
Merkle root, you've
got all these transactions.
They have a specified order.
Transaction 0 is the
coinbase transaction.
And it's special.
It generates new coins,
and it takes fees
from all the other
transactions in the block.
I think Neha mentioned
this yesterday,
where if you have a difference
between the input amounts
and output amounts,
that's implicitly a fee.
So if your input--
so here, Neha's thing,
you're spending 20 coins.
You've got 5, 10, 4.
Well, there's only 19
coins in the output,
so there's an implicit
fee of 1 coin.
That one coin can go
to transactions 0.
So transaction 0 has
essentially no input.
Transaction 0's input
field is just empty,
anything you want to put, any
bytes you want to put in there.
Its output field
generates new coins.
So that's currently
12 and 1/2 coins.
So currently, if you mine
a block with only TX0,
you get 12 and 1/2 coins.
If you mine a block with
thousands of transactions,
you get the 12 and 1/2
coins plus the difference
between the input and outputs
of all the other transactions
in the block, which can
be even more than 12
and-- which can recently,
like in January or December,
there were quite a few blocks
where they're getting 25, 26,
27 coins, because the total
fees for the entire block
were more than 12 and 1/2 coins,
which is hundreds of thousands
of dollars now.
So it's kind of cool.
The fees have since decreased.
Fees are highly variable.
And we'll talk about fees
in a few more lectures.
And it's kind of a mess,
but it's an evolving area
in this whole network thing.
So you've got your
coinbase transaction.
That's important.
That's why people are doing this
stuff, because they want money.
All the other transactions
can be shuffled around.
However, they can
only spend outputs
from previous transactions.
And previous means
they have an index
within the block that's lower.
So for example, you
have transaction
B spends an output of
transaction A. Transaction A
must come first in
the block ordering.
This makes it so that you can
go through in a linear fashion
and validate every
transaction in order.
Otherwise, you'd go through,
see, OK, transaction 0, I
don't have to validate that.
That's coinbase--
transaction 1, transaction 2.
And then you see transaction 3.
It appears to be
spending something
you've never heard of.
So that would at first--
that would appear to be invalid.
And then maybe you go through
another few transactions,
say, oh, this creates the
output that this thing I just
saw before spends.
It's sort of out of order.
It makes things very
complicated to validate.
And so this rule ensures that
if you go through and just check
every transaction in order,
it'll all make sense.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there any benefit
moving earlier or later?
TADGE DRYJA: In the block?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TADGE DRYJA: No,
I don't think so.
I mean, I can't think of one.
Yeah, it's just sort of random.
A lot of times they'll
organize it by fee rate.
Or by default, they'll
just organize it
by when they saw them first.
So it's pretty arbitrary.
AUDIENCE: Does
that mean that you
have to wait until
the transaction
that the major output
has been mined,
in order spend that again?
TADGE DRYJA: No,
although if they did,
that would make the software
a lot simpler and easier
to deal with.
But that is not how it works.
So for example-- I'll draw
it-- you can have a block where
there's-- let's do it this way.
So you have TX0.
There's coinbase transaction,
transaction 1, transaction 2,
transaction 3.
And transaction 3 may be
spending something that
was generated in transaction 1.
That can happen.
So if you make transaction 1
broadcast it. it's unconfirmed.
You then make transaction
3 broadcast it,
spends transaction 1.
The miner can put
those in the blocks.
They must put it in order.
So if this happens, you
can't switch them in order.
But that's considered OK.
It makes parallel-- it makes
multi-core validation more
annoying.
If you said, no, you can only
use outputs that have already
been confirmed, then
the block validation
becomes embarrassingly
parallel, because you can just
validate every
transaction independently.
That would be kind of nice.
There's other
interesting reasons
why this is also useful.
I mean, if I were
designing it, I
would say you have to
confirm, because it just
makes things simpler.
But I was not Satoshi.
So yeah, the order
is fairly arbitrary.
Any other questions about block
ordering, Merkle root stuff?
And then we're going to
have a quick intermission
right at the halfway point.
Sounds good, so
256-second break.
So now I'll talk about the
synchronization process.
How does this actually
work in the software
when you download Bitcoin?
So first, you download Bitcoin.
You go to bitcoin.org.
of Your friend hands you
a USB drive and says,
hey, I got some good stuff, man,
this new thing called Bitcoin.
And so you've got the
Bitcoin EXE file or DMG file,
or the binary, or the code.
And you want to know what's
been going on for the last nine
years?
So first, you
download the binary,
or you compile the code.
And you verify all the GPG
signatures of this code,
if you want to do this securely.
So I'm sure everyone has their
PGP keys on the MIT PGP server
and goes to key signing parties
held on the weekends, right?
Yeah, no?
AUDIENCE: Keybase is cool.
Base
TADGE DRYJA: Keybase
is also useful, yeah.
So I have my PGP key
hash on my business card.
I don't think anyone's
actually ever used it.
But the Bitcoin nerds
actually do do this.
And they're very sort
of annoying about it,
because a really
good attack vector
is to get someone to download
compromised Bitcoin code.
It's like the best
attack vector ever
if you're trying to do
something sneaky, mainly just
to steal all the money.
If you get them to download
a Bitcoin binary that you
control, that you put
some backdoor code in,
the code can be like two lines.
It's like, open a TCP
connection to my computer.
Send me all the private keys.
We're good.
Or if you want to be
more sophisticated,
every time they click Send
and type in their password,
I just change all the addresses
and all the outputs to me,
and like, every time
they try to send money.
To UI sort of shows that they're
sending money but actually just
send to me.
And they won't find
out for a little while.
There's a lot of
things where you
want to be running the
right Bitcoin code.
And that's a hard problem.
Because we're sort of
operating in this Trust List,
decentralized
network, how do you
get into this in the beginning?
If it's your friend
and saying, hey, here's
the Bitcoin I'm running.
I know this is good.
Then it works.
But just a website-- what if
someone hacks the website--
things like that?
It's like a huge rabbit hole.
And you can try to worry
about it for years.
But anyway, you
download the binary,
assume you've somehow
gotten the binary,
and you're pretty sure
it's the right software.
So how do you connect
to this network?
Well, there are these
hardcoded DNS seeds in order
to find peers in the beginning.
If you know how DNS works, it's
how you look up IP addresses
based on a hostname.
There are some servers that will
return multiple different IP
addresses every
time you query them.
And those are IP addresses
of currently running
Bitcoin nodes.
So the idea is, OK, someone's
running a Bitcoin node.
They've got their DNS server.
You query that DNS server,
and it will hand you
out some IP addresses.
This is also sort
of centralized,
slash trusted, slash whatever,
in that if someone compromises
these four or five
DNS servers, you
might not be able to connect
to the Bitcoin network.
So in practice, it's not
completely mathematically
secure in Trust List.
There's all these
real-world issues
that's like, how do I know
I've got the right software?
How do I know I'm connecting
to the actual Bitcoin network?
What if my ISP is
blocking me and sending me
to some other network,
or things like that?
So in practice, it sort
of works OK right now.
You connect to the DNS seeds.
And then you connect
to a Bitcoin node,
and you ask for headers.
You say, hey, I just showed up.
I know about one header.
There's a hardcoded header in
the code called the genesis
block that Satoshi did.
And you say, hey, I've
got this genesis block.
Do you know anything that builds
above this genesis block, that
comes after?
And they say, yes, I
actually know 500,000 headers
that come after it.
And they'll start
sending it to you.
They send it to you in
a couple of thousand
of headers at a time.
And then you start to download
all those and verify them.
The header chain,
you get it first.
And it's actually very quick.
You can do it in under a minute
if you have a good internet
connection.
And you verify all the work
before you do anything else.
So this is nice in that
the attacker, in order
to sort of make you
do more work here,
would have to do a
lot of proof of work.
But for you, it's very
quick to verify everything.
Even half a million
headers, 30 seconds
if you've got a good internet
connection, something
like that, because all you're
doing is one hash per header.
You just download the
header, check the bits,
check the time, make
sure the times are
like progressing reasonably.
If the times keep going
backwards for like,
I think it's 10 blocks, then
you consider it invalid.
But your computer
can actually do this.
It's 500,000 hash functions.
And I'm sure if you've
seen for the problem set,
you can do that in a few
seconds in many cases.
So you can verify the work
done throughout the entirety
of the Bitcoin's
existence pretty quickly.
So then you've got
500,000 headers.
And now you need to actually
download the blocks.
Any questions about
header synchronization?
Seems pretty
straight-- oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you
catch any of that work,
since you're going to see some
of these every time you sync?
TADGE DRYJA: Well, yeah,
you save it to disk.
So you don't have to, like,
if you shut your computer off,
turn it on the next
time, you've already
got all those headers on disk.
Basically, you save them to
disk once you've verified them.
So you download a
couple thousand.
It builds linearly,
so it's nice for you
to like download them, validate,
and as you validate, write them
to disk.
And then when you start
backup, they're on disk.
You trust your own disk.
If someone goes in
and modifies things
on disk between running of
Bitcoin, all bets are off.
So you sort of
implicitly trust that.
So yeah, that's pretty
quick, works well.
Then you get to
the real hard part,
where you now have to
validate all these signatures
and download all
these transactions.
Any other questions?
Good?
So then it's called IBD,
initial block download.
So you get the headers first.
That's quick.
Now you start asking
your peers, hey, here's
this header from
2009, block height 1.
Here's the header.
Can you give me the full block?
I have the header.
What are all the things that
go into the Merkle root?
So you request
blocks from peers.
You match the transaction lists,
the Merkle root and the header.
And you process each
transaction in order.
So download it.
Say, OK, here's all
these transactions.
Let me take the
hash of all of them.
Compute the Merkle root.
Make sure it matches
the Merkle root
I see in the header
I've already gotten.
And now process
each transaction.
So what do we do to
process transactions?
So you've got this UTXO DB.
So this is unspent
transaction output.
So all the cool--
I'm sure in like 2030, there
will be a new slang term
where we'll just
call money UTXOs,
like, hey I've
got a lot of UTXO.
I mean, I'm already doing that.
And I'm pretty ahead
of the times, so.
So you've got this
database, which
is basically a key-value store.
And it just has
transaction ID index--
so this sort of how
you reference inputs
in Bitcoin, the transaction
ID index as the key.
And then the value
is just the output,
the scriptsig and 8-byte amount.
So it's pretty compact.
You've got all these key values.
And it's using level DB.
But you could use some other
key-value store database.
And the idea is, OK, every
time you get a transaction,
validate all the inputs.
Make sure all the
signatures are good.
Make sure it's spending
things that actually
exist in your UTXO set.
And delete those inputs
from your UTXO DB.
You say, OK, this
transaction is spending
these inputs, so delete.
So [INAUDIBLE], sorry.
First, make sure the
transaction's valid,
given your current UTXO DB.
So validate that all
these inputs exist.
Validate all the
signatures are correct.
Then you're saying, OK,
this transaction is good.
Now I modify my database by
deleting all the inputs that
are consumed and adding
all these new outputs
for the transaction.
So this modifies the
database in place.
And you're sort of
constantly reading
from it to validate
inputs, and then writing
to it to delete inputs,
and then writing to it
again to add outputs.
So it doesn't seem too bad.
But there's a lot
of disk access.
And the UTXO DB is a key-value
store with a lot of keys.
The values are very small.
So it's not like a
crazy database problem,
if anyone's interested
in databases and stuff.
But it can be slow.
And we want to
really optimize it.
So when you think the
initial block download,
you're doing this
300 million times.
So there's about 300 million
transactions historically.
So you're validating signature,
deleting input, adding
output, 300 million times.
It ends up being about 170
gigabytes of downloads.
And then the end
result, when you're
done modifying this
database, is that you
have 55 million transaction
outputs remaining.
And it's about 3.2
gigabytes of disk use.
So yeah, but you had to download
that 170 gigabytes to get
to the 3.2-gigabyte
end state, because most
of the transactions that
have been created and most
of the outputs have
then later been spent.
So there's a lot of churn.
So yeah, of the 300 million--
sorry, these are not
the same numbers.
I was actually looking.
How many transaction
outputs have been created
throughout all of Bitcoin?
And I couldn't find the number.
And I didn't want to write
software to figure it out.
But you can certainly figure
it out from the blockchain.
But yeah, this is
transaction outputs.
How many total
transactions have TXOs?
I'm not sure.
But yeah, so it's pretty big.
But it's reasonable.
Like, we can do this
on today's computers.
If you've got a decent
laptop, this is possible.
This total time taken
depends on a lot of factors.
Has anyone actually done
initial block download
and synced to Bitcoin
node, and like,
want to say about how
quickly they did it or?
OK, James, how long did it take?
AUDIENCE: For 0.15, it's
actually quite quick.
On a spinning disk it will
take about six hours maybe.
TADGE DRYJA: On a spinning disk?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah, with the
new one, it's really quick.
TADGE DRYJA:
Because I run 0.15.1
on a laptop with
a spinning disk,
and it'll take like overnight
to just sync up a week or so.
It's really slow,
but I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Like, my
mum tried to start it,
and it did it from scratch.
It did it in like eight hours.
TADGE DRYJA: Wow, cool, so eight
hours to do the whole thing--
anyone else have tried it?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: A while back
it took me a week.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, a
while back it took a week.
So the software has been
improved quite a bit.
So if you downloaded it--
like, I first
downloaded it in 2011.
And it took overnight
to download everything.
And the download
was vastly smaller.
It was less than a gigabyte to
download the entire blockchain.
So what's interesting
is that the time taken
for initial block download
over the last seven years
has been somewhat constant
in that the blockchain gets
bigger and bigger.
But there's all
these optimizations
to the code and the databases.
And so that sort of keeps pace.
Although actually, I'd say
recently it's gotten faster,
because like 0.15--
wait, 0.11 or 0.12 had
a big speed-up as well.
AUDIENCE: They completely
refactored the net web code.
It used to be couples
of the synchronization.
And then they decoupled it.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, I think
that was mostly Cory, right?
So Cory Fields, who
also works for the DCI,
helped to refactor the
code, make it a lot faster.
There's definitely still
optimizations, a lot of cool--
a lot of it's pretty low-level
tweaks kind of stuff.
But some of them are
pretty big things.
Most of the big things,
low-hanging fruit,
has already been gotten.
The worry is that long-term,
this just keeps going up.
As the blockchain gets
bigger and longer,
it's going to take heart.
It's going to be
harder to validate.
It can be parallelized
to some extent.
But there's also network I/O
concerns, things like that.
So it's tricky but doable.
Any questions about
initial block download?
Good?
So here's a question.
You've got this UTXO DB.
What about this 170 gigabytes?
Do you have to store it?
Or can you delete it?
This you can't delete, right?
So you think this is OK?
Yeah, you can maybe
delete some of this.
Actually, there's
a lot of research
into maybe we can delete
this, accumulators, cool stuff
like that.
It would be really cool to have
some kind of data structure
where we can keep adding these--
we can add, remove, and
prove, and then seek,
and see if something's
in there, where it either
is like constant size, or login
size, or something like that.
That'd be really cool.
There are constructions
like that,
but they don't work for what
we're trying to do right now.
But there's a lot of
research into that.
If anyone here finds
some cool data structure
that you can use for the UTXO
DB that doesn't keep growing
linear at size of the number
of keys, everyone in Bitcoin
will sing your praises forever.
But it's an active
research area.
So pruning-- by default-- oh,
that should be a K, not an M,
sorry.
There's only 500K
blocks, not 500M.
Anyway, by default, your client
will download all these blocks
and store them on the disk.
And that's important
because what if someone
else requests them from you?
Everyone starts out as a noob.
Someone else comes
and says, hey, guys,
I just downloaded Bitcoin.
What's going on for
the last nine years?
And you might want
to give them blocks
to let them into the system.
So you can serve to
others who are doing IBD.
However, if you want, and
your hard drive's small,
or you have an SSD
or something, you
can prune and delete the
blocks after you've done IBD,
with no loss of security.
Anyone think of
downsides doing so?
Not really, right?
The only real downside
is sort of this.
Well, not everyone can prune.
If everyone prunes, no new
entrants to the system.
So it's a little
bit of a tricky sort
of seed versus leech
kind of problem,
where someone's got to be
there to serve up these blocks.
You don't have to trust them.
You're still validating
all the work,
validating all the signatures.
They can't do anything bad.
But someone's got to be there
to provide the network capacity.
And so it is tricky.
Like, most of the
nodes on the network
are behind people's cable
modem firewall kind of thing.
So you can't actually
connect to them and download.
And if you run a node
that does allow people
to connect in and
serve them blocks,
people will download
quite a bit.
So I have one in the
office over there.
It ends up sending out about
three terabytes a month,
which is a lot.
Like, it's dozens of gigabytes
a day, 20, 30, I don't know.
So yeah, people are doing this.
People are connecting in and
downloading all the blocks,
either through IBD
or just keeping up
with current transactions.
So yeah, pruning is possible.
But not everyone can do it, so
it's sort of an unsolved issue
there.
There's a lot of
research into how
we can do partial
pruning, where, OK, I'm
going to only store the last
month's worth of blocks, which
is mostly what people do,
because a lot of people
have intermittent connectivity,
where they'll turn off
their node and then start it
back up again a few days later.
And they just need to catch
up with the last few blocks.
So pruning's cool.
That's been in since
0.12 or something.
So I'll go through--
in practice, if you go
to your Bitcoin node,
what does that actually store?
And if you just go to
your Bitcoin folder,
which in Unix-type OS's is
like home directory /.Bitcoin--
total random aside,
I don't like how
they put a dot in front of all
the really important folders.
It's like they hide all the
important things, like your GPG
folder, It's got a dot.
And your Bitcoin
folder's got a dot.
But like, downloads doesn't.
And like, who cares about that?
Anyway, so if you just
ls in your folder,
here's all the files.
And we'll just go
through it real quick.
Here's the files,
and I'll describe.
So there's a banlist.dat.
This is a list of IP
addresses that you have
banned, because they're bad.
They're doing something weird.
So I'll get to it at the end.
I sort of am thinking of making
a ban list for the problem set,
because there are some nodes
that are doing non-good things.
That was what caused
yesterday's outage.
Someone was connecting.
Although it was really my
fault, because the server code
was not verifying
inputs correctly.
But yeah, in Bitcoin,
you verify everything.
If people start sending you
nonsense data, or they say,
hey, here's a block,
and it's wrong,
or hey, here's a transaction,
and the signatures are wrong,
you'll pretty quickly ban
them, because it's like, well,
if they're making a mistake--
it's computer.
There's no excuse
for making a mistake.
So either their software is
just different than mine,
or something's wrong with their
software or their hardware,
I don't know.
But they're wasting my time.
They're sending
me nonsense-- ban.
So you have your own ban list.
Then the blue ones are folders.
I'll talk about those later.
But you have peers.dat,
which is good nodes.
So it's quite a
bit, 4 megabytes.
And you keep track of here's
all the different nodes
I've connected to for
the duration of however
long I've been using Bitcoin.
I keep track of all
their IP addresses,
how much uptime they've had,
what I've downloaded from them.
And so I sort of sort them and
put the good ones at the top.
And like, OK, here's all
the different Bitcoin nodes.
So next time I start
up Bitcoin, I'm
going to try to connect to them.
So this makes the
network very robust,
because everyone
remembers everyone else.
And then when they need to--
if there's a network
disruption, maybe half the nodes
go off the network,
you can still
try to connect to all the rest.
And also peers will share their
peers files, not directly,
but they'll sort of take
random samplings of this file
and share it with each other,
so that everyone sort of
knows about everyone else.
Then there's a wallet.dat,
which is very important,
because that's got all
your precious UTXOs.
And we'll talk about
wallets Monday, I think.
There's a bitcoin.conf,
little config file.
You can set some settings
and things like that;
a debug file, which shows
all these weird messages;
and a mempool.dat.
So the mempool is a transaction
you've seen that you've not
seen in a block yet.
So people are
broadcasting transactions.
And you store them.
It used to be just in memory,
hence the word "mempool."
Now it's more like disk
pool, because you actually
store them on disk, because it
saves a little speed when you
shut down and start up again.
So any questions about just
what all these files are doing?
Makes sense, so now the folders.
Chainstate blocks
and database-- so any
guesses onto how
big these things are
based on previous slides or?
So how big is
chainstate, for example?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: 3 gigs.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, 3 gigs.
This is a UTXO set, 3-ish gigs.
This is all the blocks.
What?
Oh, no.
And then database,
actually, I have no idea.
Does anyone know what that is?
There's a database folder, and
it's got one little log file.
And it's like 80 kilobytes.
I don't know what it is.
Do you guys know?
Yeah, I don't know.
But there's a blocks folder,
and that's got all the blocks.
And that's your
huge amount of data.
And this is the UTXO
set, not too bad.
So yeah, you can look in it.
It's reasonable but
yeah, it's kind of big.
So any questions
about the data stuff?
I'm going to go into
blockchain as a database,
real quick at the end.
So it's 186 gigabytes,
or alternatively, you
can think of it as
just 3 gigabytes.
But it's a really
crummy database.
So I've heard a
lot that blockchain
is going to change the world.
And it's like a database
that's shared among everyone.
And you can query things.
It's a really bad database.
So for example,
I'm going to have
some fun interactive
questions, where some of these
are answerable.
Some of these are not.
And I'm posing the question
to my Bitcoin node.
So I posed this question
Hey, remember transaction
9e95c3 dot, dot, dot,
from back in 2014?
And how do you think the
Bitcoin node will answer?
Will it answer, or
will it not be able to?
Any ideas?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wait, where does
one be easiest [INAUDIBLE]??
TADGE DRYJA: 183 plus 3,
so the total data usage
on this computer is 186 gigs.
The rest are kind of small.
AUDIENCE: What do you mean?
TADGE DRYJA: So I mean like,
when you're using Bitcoin,
you've got 186 gigs
on your hard drive
or your SSD devoted to Bitcoin.
So you've got this 186-gigabyte
database, essentially.
But it's a really
crummy database.
And it can't do a lot of the
things you might expect it to.
So for example, this--
arbitrary transaction
from the past-- you say,
hey, there was this transaction
a couple of years ago.
Give me the
information about it.
And what do you think the
response from the full node is?
AUDIENCE: It's valid.
TADGE DRYJA: What, sorry?
AUDIENCE: It's
valid or not valid.
TADGE DRYJA: It's
Any other ideas?
AUDIENCE: What's the header?
TADGE DRYJA: What, sorry?
AUDIENCE: What's the
header of [INAUDIBLE]??
TADGE DRYJA: It asks
instead for a header.
Any other ideas?
Yeah, so sort of that--
it'll say, remember TX disk?
No, it's somewhere
in the blocks maybe,
but I have no idea where.
It's not in the chainstate.
So it just stores the blocks.
Like, here's this block.
Here's that block, in line.
And if you say, hey,
there's this transaction.
OK, go look for it.
Oh, 2014, well, that might
be somewhere in the middle.
But yeah, if you don't know
what block it's in, forget it.
So it does have an
index of blocks.
It'll tell you a block,
but transaction, no luck.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it pretty much
tells you if it exists,
and that's it.
TADGE DRYJA: It won't even
tell you if this exists.
It has no idea.
AUDIENCE: What's the
[INAUDIBLE] in the block though?
TADGE DRYJA: I might
have made that up.
So if you're saying, hey,
here's this transaction.
Do you remember it?
Does it exist?
I don't know.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you ask-- if you
query about a certain block,
will it be able to?
TADGE DRYJA: Yes, and I'll--
yeah, good question.
But I'll get to that.
I think it's in
the later slides.
But yes, if you create
your base on a block hash,
then it does have
that in the database.
And it'll be able
to get it for you.
Yeah, James.
AUDIENCE: I know what the
database directory does.
TADGE DRYJA: You know what
the database directory does.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
it's the journaling
for the other databases.
TADGE DRYJA: Journaling
for other databases--
OK, I didn't-- yeah, cool.
It's very small, so I
guess it helps things work.
So this one-- do you
know this transaction?
No.
How about this?
Well, I've got this output.
It's still there in the UTX--
like, someone spent here.
It's like, this a
transaction in the first one.
It's an op_return output.
So it's got some extra data.
But op_return
means it's invalid.
It can't spend it.
Can you tell me
what the data is?
Do you think it'll be able to?
If you query, hey,
here's this output,
what do you think
the response will be?
Yea, nay?
Nay, OK, I'm seeing nays.
Yeah.
Nope.
If it's an op_return output,
even though it's unspent,
well, it's unspendable.
So you don't put it
in the UTXO database,
because you just see, oh, this
output, op_return is in there.
Don't bother putting it in.
No one will ever be
able to spend it.
So there's no
reason to put it in.
So op_returns are
used to sort of commit
to data and all these
different protocols.
But the actual normal
code won't store them.
Anything else?
Next one, this one--
hey, I have a public key.
And here's the hash
of my public key.
This is essentially an address.
So we didn't talk
about addresses.
But the Bitcoin addresses
that start with like a 1,
and then have these
alphanumeric stuff--
it's just a different
encoding, slightly shorter
than hexadecimal,
for a pubkey hash.
So you say, hey, I've got this.
I have a private key.
I just computed the public key.
I hashed it.
I got this.
Do I have any money?
I think I did.
I don't remember.
But I remember my private key.
I backed that up.
That was the important part.
Everyone says keep
your private keys.
So I have my private key.
But all this data and
all this blockchain
stuff, I lost my computer.
But I have my private,
so I've got my money.
How many coins do I have?
How many outputs?
What do you think the
full node will tell you?
Yeah, any ideas?
It'll say, I don't know.
Well, you're going to have
to search through everything
in chainstate.
And it doesn't index based on
the public key script, only
the transaction ID index there.
It's a key-value store, and the
key is this 36-byte txid:index.
So this is a very real problem.
Like, OK, I backed up my key.
Or I took my private keys
to some other computer
or something like that.
And this is fairly--
it's gotten a lot faster.
It used to take hours,
where you had a hard drive,
and you're like, OK, import
a key to this wallet.
And it's like, well, when
did you do transactions?
It has to look through the
entire blockchain, [INAUDIBLE]
and linearly, to see if
any of these transactions
have an output that matches
that, and then says,
oh, yeah, you got
money back in 2013.
Oh, then you spent it--
and sort of replays
things, because it
doesn't have an address index.
Next one-- this is an example.
How many coins-- so you say,
hey, here's this output,
this transaction:1, how
many coins does it have?
Will the full node be
able to tell you this?
Yea, nay?
I'm seeing a bunch of nays.
No, it will.
Yeah, this is the
one thing it can do.
So if you say, hey, 7434,
dot, dot, dot, colon 1,
it'll know that.
That's in the UTXO DB,
because that's the key
that the UTXO DB sorts by.
So yep, this is a UTXO.
It's unspent.
And it has a bunch of coins.
And this is fairly recent.
I was just looking through.
Someone got a couple
million bucks worth, cool.
Is that a million?
Man.
Yeah, it's a new UTXO
set, hasn't been spent,
and you can sort quickly
based on txid:index pair.
So I think this is in
some software called
an outpoint, where it's
like, you concatenate them.
And it ends up being 36 bytes.
This is 32 bytes.
This is 4.
So you sort of have
a 36-byte outpoint,
which describes what goes
into the UTXO database.
AUDIENCE: But once
it gets respent,
it's hard to find it again.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah,
once this is spent,
you delete it from the UTXO, and
you won't remember it anymore.
It'll just be, hey, you, how
many coins does this have?
You're like, well-- well,
you can still answer it.
You say "none."
If it's spent, and you say, how
many coins does this guy have?
None.
It's not in the UTXO set.
Yeah, so the previous one--
I just copied these randomly.
So any questions about what is
stored and what is not stored?
Basically, keeps
track of UTXOs, and it
keeps track of historic
blocks in order
to give them to people.
And it keeps after the headers.
The headers ends up being small.
All the headers
total is like, what?
40 megs, something like that.
So yeah, you can
add further indices.
You could write software to
answer all these questions
very quickly.
But that's not what
Bitcoin does by default.
Those types of indices would
take a lot of extra space
and add a lot of CPU
or things like that.
So a very common thing
is an address index,
so people can ask if
they have any money.
So the second to last
one, where you say,
hey, I have this key hash.
Do I have any money?
Do I have any transactions?
Having an address
index is actually
pretty useful for
a lot of things,
for example, importing keys or
like web wallet kind of things.
But Bitcoin by default doesn't
do it, because, well, why?
You can make arguments that
it would be actually useful
to have in the normal
code, but we don't.
Any other questions about
what indices, what it can do,
what it cannot do?
Somewhat counterintuitive in
many cases, where you say, hey,
here's this transaction.
And you can't actually find it.
Or you have to scan through 180
gigabytes in order to find it.
So wait, James, I
have a question.
So how big is an address index
for what you were working on?
AUDIENCE: Usually, equal to
the size of the chain inside.
TADGE DRYJA: Wow, so it
could be hundreds of gigs.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It only takes what?
At least for Bitcoin, it
takes usually multiple weeks
to generate.
TADGE DRYJA: Weeks to generate?
I bet you, well--
AUDIENCE: Although [INAUDIBLE]
usually takes a few days
on the inside, which is
what [INAUDIBLE] takes--
weeks.
TADGE DRYJA: Well,
that's inside.
So the other thing is, these
are like fairly involved sort
of CSE software
engineering problems.
And optimization really works.
If you download like Bitcoin
0.9, it'll still work.
But you're never
going to catch up.
Maybe not never, I don't know.
If you have a fast computer, but
it'll take months and months.
And as people have been
updating the software
and making it faster,
making it more efficient,
now it's quite fast.
And you can sync the
whole thing in a few hours
on a good computer.
So address index is one
of those things where
it hasn't had like the full
force of all these Bitcoin
protocol coder people on it,
because it's sort of seen
as like, well, yeah that's kind
of a fun feature if you want.
But it's not like a
core utility of Bitcoin.
So yeah, it is a database,
maybe not the best way
to think of it though.
Don't think of the blockchain as
like a global shared database,
because it sort of is.
But it's a fairly
specific database
that isn't useful for
many other things.
Yeah, and it's also untrusted.
Another part of why
is it's untrusted.
Most of these things
exist so that they
can be used over the
peer-to-peer peer network.
If you request a block,
I'll give it to you.
If you give me a
transaction, I'll
match it against my UTXO set.
But an address index
doesn't work that way.
It's sort of trusted.
I can easily omit things.
If you say, hey, I've got a key.
What are the transactions
involved with this key?
I can omit things very
easily, and there's
no way for you to
prove it or verify it.
So your DB queries aren't really
given out to network peers.
And network peers are scary.
And you need to ban
them if they act funny.
And this happens all the time.
If you look through
Bitcoin logs,
and you have a node that's
up, every few seconds, you're
going to be disconnecting
from someone or banning them,
because they're doing something
crazy, trying to hack into you
or whatever.
So basically, all
you're doing is
you're providing headers,
blocks, transactions.
And you're sharing the
other IPs and nodes.
You try to simplify it.
Other questions?
Yeah, bad database, good for
consensus, it kind of works.
Everyone's got
the same UTXO set,
even though they
all really would
like to change that UTXO set.
I would much rather
everyone had a UTXO
set where I had
those 27-coin UTXO.
So almost everyone
in the systems
would rather there was
a different UTXO set.
And yet, they all managed to
agree on a single UTXO set,
so pretty cool.